[Music]
welcome back to the youtube channel it's
your favorite village boy mr ghana baby
and i've always been telling you guys
that agriculture is the future and i'm
not gonna stop talking about this until
i see the youth of africa investing in
agriculture i am a farmer i'm not a
fisherman but i keep on telling you guys
that the things that we overlook those
are the things that can earn us more
money i mean most of you are telling me
that we don't have enough money to
invest into real estate we don't have
enough money to invest in industries in
africa but i want to tell you that you
have enough money to invest in a farm
and this is why i brought this episode
which is titled teaching you how to what
farm in africa with little amount of
money i'm not saying it's all about
going to the farm to weed yeah it's all
about investing a little amount of money
to
do pay for things
surrounding you that will earn you more
money and that is why i'm bringing you a
new episode this episode is not about
only interviewing young africans i can
interview anyone i mean anyone who has
something to teach you so that
the thousand ghana city that you have
the thousand dollars that you have in
your pocket you can use it to invest in
something meaningful surrounding you my
name is mr ghana baby come with me it's
10 minutes episode and i'm gonna see you
as soon as i'm done don't forget to like
the video subscribe and be part of this
awesome family two million this year
i'll see you all
[Music]
you know what i saw you on the internet
and i had to come and look for you but
on the internet when i read your profile
they told me you're kenyan yes yes i'm a
kenyan you're a kenya yes i'm born third
generation kenya third generation of
indian origin um
you speak swahili yes i speak swahili
um
i don't know what even i'm saying man
jeez man my master is so bad nikon
awarded maya the legend himself
it's a pleasure meeting you and i have
the reason why i came to see you today
is like i realized that you're doing
something new something different i'm
trying to um inspire so many young
africans to invest in africa with little
amount of money and that's what's led me
to your house so this is where you live
yes this is where i live this is my
backyard and you can see i have fresh
fish coming right from my backyard
you're doing everything at your backyard
this is my backyard and this is the
concept we want to develop because
because of urbanization a lot of people
are moving to cities and they don't have
huge tracts of land to put up ponds
so we are trying to encourage urban
aquaculture in your backyards
you know what i know when it comes to
fish farming the ones that i've visited
i mean it's huge it can take the whole
area yes but you're just doing it right
at your backyard yes yes yes and this
this is biofloc technology now what you
see them doing in huge ponds i'll
explain to you in a huge pond okay if it
is unmanaged
from an acre of a land and a pond on an
acre of land when you have not managed
your pond you can get around six to
eight tons of fish from that one acre
with my technology if you put it on one
acre you will get more than 70 tons of
fish
that is the difference you said my
technology i mean this technology is not
my technology this this technology was
actually developed in the us and in
israel
way back in the 1990s okay and it is
used a lot
in in other countries especially in asia
where whereby they need to bring down
the cost of production because
everything is very highly competitive so
they need to bring down the cost of
production so they use a lot of this
technology okay to produce more at a
lower cost
you know what um we are in ghana yeah
before you take us to go and see what
you're doing you're in ghana right now
but you said you're born in kenya 10th
generation what brought you to ghana
then uh i came to ghana initially i used
to work for a bank
and then i i stopped that and i started
my own
manufacturing of tarpaulin okay
so we manufacture the topology one of
the products we manufacture is the
topolin tanks for the fish you
manufacture right here yes we
manufacture in ghana
we we produced them in ghana oh yes and
then after that pollen we decided to so
when i had the tarpaulin and i saw that
there is a need to bring in this
technology and because i was trained
also in this technology in india okay in
biofloc i decided to now try and
introduce this technology using our
tanks
you can also do cement tanks but those
are a bit more expensive this is cheaper
and we want to try and bring down the
cost of production as much as possible i
am here because
so many africans that watch me
especially the young ones are saying
that it's so expensive to invest in
africa how much do you think it will
cost us to i mean invest in this type of
technology okay for this type of
technology for example this is a three
meter diameter tank because i don't have
a lot of space but the basic commercial
size
is a four meter diameter tank which can
take ten thousand liters of water
whoa yeah so that ten thousand liters of
water can give you around uh 300 to 500
kilos of fish
now depending on how you are harvesting
if you are harvesting at say 300 grams
you are talking of 1 600 tilapia from a
four meter diameter tank from your
backyard can we just go and check it out
i don't know if you're willing to train
people for me because that's the reason
why i'm here
um how do we reach out to interns if
somebody wants consultation or want to
know how to okay i'm doing this in their
backyard yeah we we have a website uh
www.bioflocaafrica.com
so you can reach us through the website
our contacts and everything is there all
the details are there so we have four
four uh services and products one is the
training so we'll be training people on
this technology and uh in sub-saharan
africa we would be the first trainers of
this technology there are farms there's
one in malawi and one being set up in
south africa but those are big scale
they are not for small-scale farmers
so we would be the first
africans to train africans in africa
i love that the fact that he's stressing
on africa
for africans that's awesome you know
what i just want to ask you a question
you've lived in africa all your life
born and raised in here
what is that one thing that if you had a
chance to change up in africa you would
change what was that one thing
it is these technologies that we need in
africa
and the people who have these
technologies are not very happy to give
them to us
they want us to go for technologies like
ras which is the recirculating
aquaculture system which is very
expensive it's a white elephant so it's
an expensive system to implement
and also a very expensive system to run
now when i'm talking of ras i'm talking
about the proper areas where you have
your bio filters you have mechanical
filters you have ue
all those techniques
sophisticated technologies i'm not
talking about the technology where we
take buckets and we put pebbles and we
put some ceramic stones and we say that
is rs i'm not talking of that res i'm
talking of the proper areas that is a
very expensive system and that is what
people want us to use because that is a
white and it is not going to work unless
you are doing very high value fish
because the cost of running that
technology will not pay you when you
harvest your fish so these are the kind
of technologies that we need to bring to
africa for africans to benefit from and
that is my objective so this it's it's
it's profitable and sustainable
what is your name once again my name is
and like i said i'm i'm a kenyan
based here in ghana for the last few
years
just to give you a bit of perspective
about the the technologies okay so on
one side of the spectrum we have the
pond technology okay where you dig a
pond and you leave your fish in that you
will get around five to six tons per
acre
on the extreme side we have the ras
system recirculating aquaculture system
there you can get 50 plus kilos per
cubic meter of water but the cost of
implementing that technology is huge
and is not really for anybody on a small
scale to do
this technology can give you around 30
to 50 kilos depending on your level of
expertise and your training
okay at a fraction of the cost
of doing an ras system and people can
put this in their backyard this you can
even put inside your room because
there's absolutely no smell as you can
see
one of the other benefits of this system
again is you see because uh the protein
is being generated in the system the
microbial protein we recommend even that
you use low protein feed
now low protein feed what does that do
it reduces the cost of feed so when
people start taking this technology up
and the feed producers start producing
the low protein cost fear feed
the cost of feed will come down
so in addition to you saving on the
amount of feed you are also saving on
that type of feed because the protein
content has reduced
what that also does for the environment
is because we get a lot of the protein
from the oceans we are taking a lot of
the fish from the oceans to convert into
fish feed
as fish meal
so we will now reduce that pressure on
the environment
and use that fish for humans and then in
this technology we reduce our our
consumption of
fish protein the last benefit that i
want to talk about is the
health benefit you see this is organic
fish when you eat organic things you
become healthy so now if you look at the
macro level
when people stop falling sick the
pressure on our health systems will also
reduce
so it has a macro benefit also in
addition to the micro for the small
people
if you look at the economic benefits
those are huge imagine if everybody has
or maybe a thousand people in ghana have
this tank in their backyard and you're
producing a ton of fish every every six
months or five months
ghana imports 250 million dollars worth
of fish
now we can shift that balance in our
favor
instead of importing we can now even
become exporters of organic fish
you understand so that is one benefit
another benefit is if you put this in
the schools
the children can benefit from good
quality protein on one hand on the other
hand you see this is a very scientific
technology
so what they learn in science
they will apply it straight into this
on a practical level and those children
can then become aquapreneurs when they
leave school they don't need to really
pursue
other courses they can go into
aquaculture so we can grow that another
area we can look at is even the prisons
for example we can train the inmates in
this technology so by the time they come
back to join society they are already
skilled and they have ready jobs waiting
for them you see if i if i take you to
kenya for example this this is what i
call an appropriate technology for
africa
if you look at kenya for example we
started appropriate technology in
agriculture as the greenhouse in the
1960s so today
kenya exports a lot of horticultural
products
as well as flowers is one of the leading
flower exporters in the world because we
started then and if you look at the
agronomists across the world and
particularly in africa they come from
kenya why because they built the
expertise over the years now ghana with
me here and with this technology and we
have that unique advantage that we can
train our people so that by the time the
other countries try and catch up with us
we have a pool of experts who we can
then export to the other countries
so that is an advantage we have and this
technology is the technology of the
future it's the blue revolution in
aquaculture
and this is what people should adopt if
they want to get profitable output and
this this can be used for any fish if it
can work for tilapia
you can use this for catfish with your
eyes closed
i don't know since we've been mentioning
so many advantages what are the
disadvantage of using this method okay
there are no i wouldn't call them
disadvantages because there are no
disadvantages they are only challenges
there are small challenges like every
system has a challenge
the first and the most important
challenge of this technology is the
training
training is extremely important
you have to be properly trained to be
able because all this is based on
scientific principles and you have to
understand the scientific principles
before you can manage the water so
training is the most important thing
second challenge is that it needs some
preparation time so you don't just fill
your water and bring fish and you put
them inside it will not work so there is
a preparation time you have to prepare
the water you have to prepare the fish
and then you can start and once you do
that your mortality is almost zero you
should not get any mortality
so that is one of the the the challenges
another challenge is electricity you
must have constant electricity if
especially you are doing tilapia even
for catfish if you are doing catfish the
system still needs aeration because you
want to keep it an
aerobic environment you don't want
anaerobic
uh
status this car cannot use solar it can
use solar it can use any form of
electricity but you have to have
electricity and a backup so when when
lights go off you have to have your
backup taking off
okay but is it expensive to go for the
training
no training is not very expensive it's
not expensive in that
is the most important thing so you you
can decide to go for this invest a lot
of money and a lot of people have done
that because they are trying to save
that training cost
so they invest a lot of money without
going for training and then they end up
failing so losing a lot of money you see
training also once you go for the
training and you understand the
technology you will be able to know
whether really that technology is for
you or not for you because it needs some
dedication you have to be able to check
the parameters manage the parameters it
takes a bit of your time say 10 minutes
every morning you need to spend on the
time and and you are fine you're good to
go so training is the most important
without training you you will not be
able to do this and then and then this
this technology you see with these tanks
because we make them ourselves we can
make any size for you so if you want a
five meter diameter tank you want 10
meters 20 meters whatever size you want
we can make it for you in this now after
this we are going to bring another
technology for ponds
this is for tanks that is for ponds so
where you have a pond and you already
have and with that technology you will
be able to increase your production by
five to thirty times what you're
currently doing
so that technology will we will bring it
we will introduce it
later so i'm gonna put a website link
for you guys to um check it out if you
want to um enroll for the training and
um yeah it's it's more affordable and go
learn it and start this wherever you are
like i said this year i'm teaching you
how to fish i mean the easiest way to
fish with a little amount of money thank
you so much for watching uh it's still
your favorite village by mr ghana baby
and i'm gonna see you in the next one